everybody naked sample I'm honestly I'm
picture Andrea's car work it's needs
special prep theory so what that means
is for analyzing students properties
that graph by housing the spectrum which
are operators to Latin America simply
our case we're analyzing connectedness
and by partek is by analyzing the
spectrum of these will plus one script
so it would want free
one interesting question on my task is
how how connected or we're going to have
cluster whoa like rat is so you could
have say a graph that is completely
discounted to set their quantities which
would be completely but you might also
have two obvious clusters like this with
a few edges one or one edge connected so
this is a graph that is not completely
disconnected but is very very nearly so
and so another fact that is interesting
is that mention the laplacian which is a
matrix that will define on this graph
which has a spectrum
as sine value that went from zero will
be the first eigenvalue all the way to
get the plug language Michael too it
turns out that
the second eigen value will be 0 if and
only if McGrath is disconnected so then
one might ask themselves is what if we
have very nearly discounting graph like
this might you have the technical you re
new year 0 but not quite is there like a
relation between the two it turns out
the thin effect is a form of achieving
equality
which is
so
this is the result of a key pretty much
started with
but then we realized something something
else that is true which is
it's brilliant a bipartite graphs so
bipartite graph is a graph where all the
notes can be separated into two two
different sets and all the edges in the
graph go between the two cents none
within yourself
this is an example of a bipartite graph
so those two sets here to be the
agreement degree notes the red nodes
there are no edges between green is
there no edges between threatens my part
I graphs are kind of important one of
the main reasons for protective diagrams
that
computationally speaking there's a
number of algorithms that just seemed it
work very well to wrap this by the car
tech but in any case again question on
my task is how bipartite is so even my
given graph is not completely bipartite
is in visiting close to a bit bipartite
graph right
so again we say this
so the end I valuably to is only at gsi
part a or lying a little bit here she
also has to be connected for this to be
true but the g's connected
like values to that you'll bipartite
privacy you can I kind of do the exact
same thing if I have a nearly bipartite
graph do I have Linda an equal to almost
two and so we have this
so
but the question right here because
we're not fit any purpose as strong
reason to believe this is true
fortunately the same group that means
despite there being a lot of symmetry
between these two cases Center
techniques do not quite carry over into
this case and modifying them to work for
this case sniffing the trigger than
expected nonetheless for
based on the analogy here and for given
numerous computational experiments we do
believe that this is true
happen this time we have so this
identical balance
so there is at least some relation
d by partek test
highest
so while status quo to about one
approach to
are we talking about page rank vectors
and basically there's nulls would have
approached to the graph clustering
problem and they're based on random box
so
it's important to talk about
so it was just some
the way around and walk words is started
some British
and with some probability right back at
you
fell apart
so good morning so now as you do random
walk
it'll keep track of the vertices that
so
fridge light like a real world example
Google let's explore exploited greater
works in one way by using them to
of their website sanders and
granted early stage it's ultimately the
pagerank vector is
um
with the vector probability within
so the way we can use payment vectors is
one we have to communicate I major and
two we have to look for vertices with
unusually high probability of being
visited and by and usually I mean that
the higher than we can expect by simply
looking at
so now what are the advantages of using
I
the one they're local which means that
you need only a small subset
part of interest
there are spread conversational class
because they're very
alright so a little talk a little bit
more
our analysis of bipartite graphs
typically in
instructions with the music that we've
been calling to rest
and
always go with so by partek this
two graphs in here is redone yeah
okay so um
what we're talking about kind of
clustering or finding almost
disconnected sets there's kind of an
immediate intuition as to why the
PageRank algorithm in random walks would
be useful for this and this is the idea
that if we started a vertex you and we
do a random traversal of the graph the
vertices were really likely to visit our
kind of the vertices that are in the
same cluster as our vertex you right so
in the sense if we do a page rank for
vertex u it will kind of give us a set
of vertices that were really likely to
visit and those should probably be the
vertices that are in the cluster
containing so the page rank kind of has
this immediately to ative thinking as to
why it would make sense that a
clustering problem or finding these
nearly disconnected sex unfortunately
there's not really a clear intuition as
to why the page rank and random walks
would translate really well to
understanding the bipartite graph so in
order to kind of translate our
understanding of the clustering problem
to where I understand
our debt problem we came up with this
construction that we call the to graph
so the way that we constructed in graft
is we start with some original right so
we'll look at this really simple one
here and then you can see the bigger
examples are so this is our original
graph and for it just has three vertices
and tricks for the two dropper we do is
which is a duplicate duplicate the same
set of vertices and we're going to draw
an edge between two vertices if there's
kind of a two-edged path between them in
the original graph so what that's going
to mean is in this original graph you
can see that we can get from vertex 1 2
3 X 3 by taking two steps you can go one
two two and two to three so in the to
graph what we're going to do is
going to draw vertex between one and
three we can also get from one to itself
by going from 1 a 2 and 2 back to one so
we can draw a self edge here and we saw
same way and we can get from 2 to itself
twice so we're going to start with
simple graphs where you can't have any
self edges and there will exist 1 edges
one edge uniting two pairs of vertices
and for the to graph we're going to end
up with I'm not simple graph that can't
have waited edges and sulfa news so this
is the to graph that we end up with
there's one edge between one to three an
edge between one in itself an edge
between three and itself and two edges
between two minute stuff and you can
imagine expanding this process to be in
chi regret so kind of
the intuition behind doing this and what
we ended up proving is this statement so
FG is connected to begin with then
these quantities are true and almost
kind of kind of like this game so we
have our G equals one if and only of hg
2 equals 0 RG is kind of a constant that
talks about how bipartite graph is it's
going to be a bipartite is going to be
one if the graph is bipartite and the
closer to being by part type is the
closer it is one and it should never be
zero but essentially for lower again so
the closer it gets to zero the further
away from being bipartite your graphics
a tree tree is a constant that kind of
talks about how close to being
disconnected your graph is if it's
really if it is zero it means your graph
is disconnected and it's close to zero
it means your graph is really close to
being disconnected it's really clustered
in a sense so what this tells us is that
our original graph would be bipartite if
and only if our to graph is completely
disconnected so we get kind of a graph
originally as part time as possible only
if our to graph is as clustered as
possible so we kind of see here our
relationship between by partek nests of
our original graph and the end the
cluster ability of our to graph so we
wanted to expand that relation because
this is only in a very specific case
because finding the best part debt set
for the best clustered set is an np-hard
problem which is very computationally
expensive so actually
finding these sets with the computers
very hard so generalizing our results to
kind of any subset is very helpful in
the sense and so in order to do that I'm
going to kind of introduce some notation
so we talked about size of us which is
kind of how bipartite
apartment is
of us has a very loose definition we
have something stricter to just kind of
course this is a measure we have a pipe
our tennis it works very much like this
measure it fits one it means that that's
a partition or subset of vertices that
acts as like a proper partition of the
graph into like a bipartite graph in
this case savings like s would be the
red vertices then this would be one
because we can see in this graph of the
green hardest seasonal repertories kind
of divided the graph intently bipartite
success and the lower this constant is
closer to zero the best buy parking and
subsidies and then we have this constant
pms which is kind of the cluster ability
of s
and it works just like this each
constant except for a general subset if
it's zero it means that set is
completely disconnected from the rest of
the graph and the closer to one it is or
the larger it gets the less disconnected
it is so the less of like its own
cluster it will be in the graph so what
we
improve on her sets that locally
maximize this measure of x park atmos is
that one minus sine of s squared is the
best
the giraffe or the number of vertices in
a graph over 2 times 5 20 s which is
kind of messy but essentially what it's
saying is that four sets that locally
maximize the resistance if their
conductance in the to graph is small it
means that their resistance in the
original graph needs to be fairly large
so we kind of have this immediate
relation that tells us that our
conductance in the to graph will give us
a good resistance in the original graph
for specific sex s what we want to
generalize this to any set because we
can't always guarantee that we're going
to find these sets if we're looking for
them so we're looking to prove an
inequality of this
and we're fairly confident that this or
something very similar is true and
essentially what this says is that if we
find a set in the to graph that has a
very good cluster ability it means that
we found a set that is either very
bipartite in the original graph or not
bipartite at all and garlic clustering
so the two graph kind of takes by partek
sets and it makes them very well cluster
in the imogen graph but it takes the bus
good sense and keeps them all clustered
as well so if we find a wall cost except
in the two craft we can't guarantee that
it was quite partite we kind of know
that it was either very close to being
bipartite or very close are very well
clustered to begin with so we have these
two results and we're looking to prove
this one still and that's kind of where
we are on
you're able travel to the tooth
ok so we've heard a lot about serious
i'm going to be talking about for the
algorithmic aspects so one question is
why even bother with algorithms because
for granny Brad it's true it's possible
to white interior defines the gear
constant which is the weight set that
has the lowest bound over volume ratio
but I've been 2 to the N hospital
subsets we're at with size and that you
have to be right over this is
impractical for large graphs so what we
did achieve with me the algorithms is
begin run times that are like the only
talking or hopefully close to linear and
the theory guarantees
results we get are not going to be very
far off from the optimum cut so let's
first talk about sex divide a tradition
you can graph into two subsets that have
boundary between them at maximum
internal
so we heard about I get vectors and page
rank vectors so if you take earlier so
if you take the eigenvector associated
to the second smallest eigenvalue or
patron factor what you'll do is you can
get an ordering of the vertices based on
this so if the third entry of the
specter say is the has the greatest
value then you'll rank the third vertex
first in your ordering the seventh
vertex has the second greatest century
will rank the SEC 73 x second so for
example supposing we have this graph
um
and we might shed this day
courtesy
it's either a drink for the eigenvector
and so now once we have this ordering
the problem is not linear because all we
have to do is integrate over what are
called a sweet set all the sweeps that's
our is the end sweet set is just the set
of the first n elements and the ordering
above so our first sweeps up would be
just this point and then it will be just
these two points 1 in 3 refers to 135
and so and as you can kind of see from
this poorly drawn grab the the best cut
will be right here because the boundary
is minimized and so what we're looking
to optimizes we want to minimize the
ratio of bounds over the volume of the
smaller and so that's very minimized
here so this is not quite linear for the
eigen
method because computing eigenvectors
takes on the order and cubed but this is
still a vast improvement over
exponential time and for the PageRank
process it is very close to linear and
in addition it's
very
and then the process is very similar
when we're trying to do try so this was
for finding sets that have minimum
boundary connections and maximal
internal connections but if we're doing
more of what pink was talking about
trying to find in two sets that have
that are maximally connected along the
boundary but have very few internal
connections the process is very
analogous to this so from k drink
instead of looking at the original graph
if you look at the two graph instead and
then you do this exact same process so
you use if you get the patron sector
looking at the two graph um and then you
try to minimize the bound over the
volume look again at the to graph um
then that will ensure that in the to rap
book two sets are very disconnected
which kind of suggests that the original
graph in the original graph the two sets
will be very common and you can also do
a similar method but using eigenvectors
but instead of using the second smallest
eigen vector of the original graph now
if you use the largest eigen vector of
the original graph you'll get an
ordering and then if you use the measure
of my part cut bipartite this which is
up there which redefines to be the bound
at the side tends to
all divided by our volume of the entire
graph and make cuts based on the largest
possible value that you get you get to
partition which guarantees or which
comes close to maximal bipartite this
yeah and so we
can we haven't like quite proven that
this works for all sets but the computer
experiments are very promising so as you
go farther I guess for you guys it's
right the graph is more bipartite which
just means that we increase the
probability of connections along the
boundary and you notice that twice the
maximum boundary of the sweep set
divided by the volume of G which is just
the bipartite this measure gets closer
and closer to one if the graph is
completely bipartite we'd expect the
boundary to be exactly half the volume
so this looks very promising the trend
is very there's a very clear trend and
similarly for the bike for the PageRank
algorithm on the to graph you notice
that now it's getting smaller but that's
because we're looking at the minimum
Keuka ratio so as the graph becomes more
bipartite then on the bound of the two
graph divided by the volume will get
closer and closer to zero and so these
things both indicate that are what we're
trying to prove looks promising
I think that's okay acid but we learn to
think they probably Oh
follow thomas or better focus all this
research
relationship between I event I a vector
say
classical classical
just between
so so is it you had two different you
have two different vectors but again
this page rank danger and an item 10 30
lucasi a mattress
they're election and listen
so they're like computationally like a
dependent
but they're they're both similar comment
so they're just differently the random
walk matrix is actually similar to the
laplacian so if you're looking at the
spectrums they have a lot of like
relationships and similarities but
computationally the mathematical seminar
not like maple yeah yeah actually
similar up to my head to the ad